[Música]
llegó revista de prensa directo a
América pero yo le doy la bienvenida a
mi compañera Marta Moya Marta muy buenos
días Hola Andrés Buenos días feliz lunes
Feliz lunes también Marta vamos a abrir
hoy revista de prensa con los Ecos que
deja la Cumbre del g7 que tuvo que tuvo
a Rusia a Ucrania y a China como
protagonistas y que por supuesto ha
recibido las críticas del gigante
asiático vamos a empezar con lo que dice
por ejemplo una editorial del global
Times pues Andrés vamos a empezar con el
global Times que ya sabemos es un medio
muy afiliado al partido comunista chino
y en este editorial post Cumbre del g7
niroshima en Japón denuncia que esta
Cumbre se ha convertido en una suerte de
laboratorio o de taller anti china
sostiene este editorial que los líderes
de la Cumbre de la Cumbre público
publicaron el documento de las
conclusiones un día antes de que
finalizara su encuentro en Hiroshima por
temor a que la visita del presidente
zelensky empañar a ese documento sin
embargo que las al final no consiguieron
atraer el interés internacional Más allá
de la parte que habla sobre china en el
documento se observa Se observa una
fuerte presión sobre el gigante asiático
el editorial del global Times dice
textualmente Parece que la única manera
de que el g7 capte la atención de la
gente y muestre su sentido Es especular
sobre los temas relacionados con china A
diferencia de otros enfoques pasados
donde Pues el g7 se centraba en aspectos
concretos de China este documento Trata
a China como un todo dice el global
Times lo cual va en línea con el
movimiento reciente de la otan
destacando que Estados Unidos que está
presionando para tejer una red antichina
en el mundo occidental recordemos que
recientemente ha habido reportes de que
la agotan plantea abrir una oficina en
Japón en 2024 lo que china ve como una
completa amenaza Además este documento
menciona a China en 20 ocasiones lo que
dices de editorial del global Times es
una interferencia brutal en los asuntos
internos de China y un impulso no
disimulado de confrontación entre
potencias que ha convertido al g7 en uno
de los mayores riesgos que enfrenta la
paz y el desarrollo en el mundo actual
Marta la prensa gráfica también ha hecho
Eco De este tema por ejemplo que nos
dice cartoon movement pues Andrés esta
plataforma destacamos una caricatura del
bille
tistaco Oliver Scoop en la que se ve a
China no como ese elefante en la
habitación en este caso representado con
su clásico dragón y vemos a los líderes
del g7 en esa foto habitual para los
medios y detrás de ese lago emerge ese
dragón chino sostiene a esta viñeta del
cartus moment que a pesar pues de esa
condena firme de los líderes del g7
contra china pues al final sigue
habiendo una gran dependencia en las
economías mundiales en mayor o menor
medida sobre todo a través del comercio
chino Andrés Marta y por ejemplo por
parte de Beijing esto lo también han
llegado reacciones o ha llegado quejas
hacia Japón esto lo recoge por ejemplo
al yasira pues Andrés este lunes el
viceministro de exteriores de China
sumaydón ha llamado al embajador japonés
en el país para expresarle su malestar
de que Japón fuera anfitrión de una
Cumbre que sostiene las autoridades
chinas ha sido antiinflamatoria para el
país el viceministro de exteriores ha
pedido colaborar con otros países del g7
ha dicho que Japón colabora perdón con
otros países del g7 y que viola los
principios básicos del derecho
internacional también este artículo de
jazzira recoge las declaraciones del
kremlin acerca de toda esta Cumbre que
dijeron que pues el g7 es una incubadora
que dice que recupera la histeria anti
rusa y antichina Marta por otra parte
desde medios occidentales como el
balance de la Cumbre pasa por el papel
de protagónico que tuvo el presidente
ucraniano Pues sí Andrés destaca El
guardián en este análisis que la clave
del g7 no pasa tanto por el documento de
las conclusiones sino por la presencia
física que hizo el presidente de Ucrania
que es quizá además la última
confirmación de que zelensky tiene que
empezar a tocar otras puertas no solo la
de sus aliados occidentales que son
esenciales para defender su resistencia
ante la agresión rusa sino que también
tiene que mirar a los países no
alineados que en sucesivas votaciones en
Naciones Unidas sean abstenido frente a
la agresión rusa esta dinámica empezó a
cambiar en octubre de 2022 cuando el
ministro de exteriores ucraniano hizo
una gira por varios países africanos y
ahora pues con zelensky la semana pasada
visitando o haciendo presencia en la
Cumbre de la liga árabe o ahora pues
teniendo una relación bilateral una
reunión bilateral perdón con el Primer
Ministro indio algo que no sé que no se
dio con el presidente brasileño Lula da
Silva precisamente Marta la ausencia de
un encuentro entre informal entre el
presidente zelensky y Lula da Silva está
hoy presente en toda la prensa brasileña
y hay confusión sobre Quién dio el paso
para que no se diera este encuentro
Aunque parece que finalmente Pues él es
que quien dejó plantado a Lula que que
dice al respecto Pues sí Andrés toda la
prensa brasileña recoge el hipotético
desplante del presidente de lensky
anulada Silva porque al final dice que
solo cumplió con uno de sus objetivos
que reunirse con arena Moody pero que
falló en el objetivo de reunirse con
Lula da Silva la reunión estuvo bajo
suspense todo el sábado y en la mañana
del domingo se fijó que ambos
mandatarios se reunieran a las 3:15 de
la tarde hora local y al final ese
encuentro no se dio porque zelensky no
llegó a la reunión zelensky en rueda de
prensa dijo que Lula estaría disgustado
por este encuentro que el final no se
dio por su parte dijo Lula que la
palabra no era disgustado sino que
estaba molesto de que no quisiera Oír
sus planes de paz en la guerra ruso
ucraniana pero que habrá otras otras
fuentes o otros encuentros en los que se
pueda dar esta reunión además dice Lula
da Silva que es una persona adulta que
sabe lo que hace y que si prefirió
priorizar otras reuniones pues al final
este encuentro se deberá posponer Marta
y terminamos hoy con un informe de The
economist que destaca los aprendizajes
de las tropas rusas tras casi un medio
de guerra en Ucrania Pues sí Andrés Este
es un parte lo que recoge es parte de el
royal United Services institute un
trabajo que ha desarrollado durante
varios meses en el que sostiene que el
ejército ruso ha tomado buena cuenta de
lo que está haciendo en Ucrania y ha
mejorado aspectos clave de su ofensiva
todo aportas de esta tan esperada
contraofensiva ucraniana que podría
poner un poco en jaque los esfuerzos de
las tropas de kiev sostiene este
artículo de día economics que las
mejores las mejoras han sido
sustanciales en tácticas de Infantería
artillería blindaje y guerra electrónica
concretamente en guerra electrónica el
kremlin ha desplegado sistemas de guerra
electrónica cada 10 km del frente y ha
derribado en el último mes Diez mil
drones ucranianos lo que da una media de
300 drones al día sin embargo sostiene
di economys que Ucrania todavía puede
vencer en su contraofensiva porque
imponer a las tropas a las tropas rusas
en una situación dinámica Es probable
que entonces las unidades ru Sas pierdan
rápidamente su coordinación eso dice di
economist Marta Muchas gracias por este
repaso sobre lo que dicen los medios de
comunicación gracias